mr. secretary week melon about the
relationship between carbon dioxide and
atmospheric warming since before the
Second World War many people don't
realize that and scientists have been
predicting climate change for 50 years
today the research is overwhelming and
conclusive I know you share that opinion
yet nothing has been done the world
needs an action plan mr. secretary give
me three practical steps that we can
take to deal with this problem now well
the short-termism is the enemy we all
face hear it clearly is and we face it
in all facets of life we face it in Wall
Street we face in Washington all kinds
of decision making so what the practical
steps that that I think have come out of
the the study we've just released which
is the first attempt and I think it's a
very good one to quantify the risk that
climate has to our economy the steps
that come out of that are are things
that I think business needs to do and
this will be a again the study is a
first attempt to to deal with this out
so for the first time we're putting out
and we're quantifying the risk not just
the immediate risk and not just the the
most reasonable cases but the the
outside risk the the the really perverse
outcomes the what I would call the tail
risk and so the things that I think come
out of this is first of all investors I
think need to demand that businesses
make disclosures and make disclosures
about the risks make disclosures about
the their carbon emissions make
disclosures about the the risk of
stranded assets the FCC could do some
things in terms of starting a debate
on those things secondly I think
business leaders in the US are the best
I've ever seen them and I think US
companies are the best managed companies
in the world but us businesses I think
need to lead on this issue and because
the investments they're making today are
really going to have a lot to do with
our economic future and and so I think
businesses need to do more in terms of
investing in resilience and then I think
most importantly we need a to take out a
national insurance policy we need the
federal government to take action right
now businesses and you know city
governments are way ahead of the
national governments and so I think
businesses need to do a better job of
lobbying in pressing the national
government to put the kinds of policy in
place that will let us avoid the the
most adverse outcomes